Glenn Beck I was just on Glenn Beck's
show not so a week or two ago
Glenn Beck one of the maybe the greatest
broadcaster alive right now
and just a staple of the American right
for a very long time
Glenn Beck
just had his podcast
removed from Apple not
one episode of this podcast
not one week of his podcasts
the whole thing was removed from the
Apple podcast app here he is this is
from Apple we found an issue with your
show The Glenn Beck program which must
be resolved before it's available on
Apple podcast your show has been removed
from Apple podcast from the Apple
podcast team they sent us to uh sent us
a link and said for more details go to
the link and the link only says your
show has been removed from Apple
podcasts well we got that one dummy
I
I mean I cannot imagine what they are
what they're basing this one on I mean
have we even had strikes nothing right
this is crazy crazy
um you need to please retweet this and
start a campaign to Apple to say put the
podcast back on
this is absolutely uh freedom of speech
there's nothing that we have said that
would warrant any removal
now I'm being told that Apple has
reinstated Glenn this morning okay
that's a good thing but hasn't given any
reason
I think I have the reason
I want to be as charitable as I can
maybe this happened it was just a little
technical glitch
I just can't help but notice that the
technical glitches always only affect
the right
the little oopsie daisies they never
they so rarely seem to affect the left
and they so consistently seem to affect
the right and I can't help but notice
what time it is can't help but notice
that we are what 14 months out 15 months
out from a presidential election and I
can't help but notice that all of the
attacks the way that YouTube has tried
to suppress this show
the way that the well Georgia and New
York and the federal government and
Biden has tried to suppress
the Trump presidential campaign can't
help but notice the way that Apple now
is trying to suppress Glenn Beck I can't
help but think that maybe
that timing is more than mere accident
but there's something a little bit more
to that coincidence this is only going
to ramp up
and the reason this is going to ramp up
is because we have a particularly
divided political order right now and
I'm not saying it's divided among the
populist 50 50. I'm not convinced that
it is it is increasingly divided between
the ruling class and the people which is
why you're seeing populist movements
rise up not just on the right you had an
actual successful populist movement on
the right which was the Maga movement
the election of trump in 2016. but
you're seeing populism on the left not
just weirdo Ralph Nader who gets three
percent of the vote but
Bobby Kennedy who's right now polling at
17 to 19 within the Democratic Party
you're seeing a real surge of populism
you're seeing the breakdown of common
media you're now seeing near parity
between people who on their TVs watch
YouTube and Netflix and people who watch
Regular old cable news and even when you
add Broadcast News into that it's still
less than half the country
so you're seeing a breakdown of that
common culture
you're seeing obviously a breakdown in
the language that we use we can't even
agree on the definition of a man or a
woman right now
so of course the ruling class is going
to get a little bit more heavy-handed I
mentioned this yesterday on the show
they're getting more heavy-handed
because there will be order
that's just a fact there what and maybe
the order will be because people control
ourselves
in order a little closer to the
political order of the country at its
founding in the the political founding
in the 18th century
maybe there will be order because the
people don't control themselves but the
states and the local communities get
more involved
maybe it's going to be an overbearing
Federal bureaucracy
and or maybe it's going to be
overbearing corporate apparatchiks
people who control the Public Square
even though they're not in elected
positions or even appointed positions
people like apple people like YouTube
people like Facebook
Elon is doing great but the the other
and that's the smallest of the big Tech
platforms the other big Tech platforms
are all on one side and they're all
they're all wielding power because there
there will be some kind of order and so
we shouldn't be surprised by this and we
shouldn't
pull our hair out and befuddlemen and we
shouldn't waste all of our breath
pointing out the hypocrisy
but imagine if the roles were reversed
but they're not reversed but this is
unfair it's not supposed to be fair
it's supposed to maintain order that's
what they're that's what they're doing
that's what they're after
and Glenn Beck threatens that order and
this show I guess threatens that order
and Donald Trump for sure has writtens
that order
and so they're going to do everything
they can
to stop it now speaking of 2024
some big news in that race because we
are one week out
in fact we're slightly less than one
week out from the first GOP Presidential
primary debate we still don't know if
president Trump is going to be at that
debate we still don't know if he's going
to be an orange jumpsuit or not for that
debate maybe maybe he won't even be able
to attend but but he's refused to sign
the RNC loyalty pledge which which says
that he'll he'll endorse the eventual
nominee if he loses and he's refusing to
sign that because he says well I don't
know if I'm going to endorse the nominee
if I if I lose and I think everyone's
been trying to rig this thing against me
since day one so uh sorry forgive me if
I don't exactly trust you guys I know
I'm not going to do that but because
he's leading by 30 points 40 points in
some places the RNC will look ridiculous
if they don't allow him to come to the
debate so where does it all stand and
where do the non-trump candidates stand
we'll get to that in one second right
now go to balanceofnature.com use promo
code Knowles living a healthy lifestyle
it's not always easy especially when
you're always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure that
you are getting proper nutrition every
day that's why I'm a huge fan of balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
capsules are packed with 100 whole food
that you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and veggies and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try we all love them it was jackals
try to steal them all away from me but
but I think we just need to get balance
of nature to send more make sure you go
check it out right now go to balance of
nature.com use promo code Knowles kwles
for 35 off your first order as a
preferred customer that's
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s for 35 off your first
preferred order right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you're
hiring you know it's incredibly
difficult to attract top talent and with
the current labor market conditions it's
even harder than ever that is why you're
going to want to partner
with SIP recruiter so recruiter gets it
zip recruiter knows how tough it is
right now they've figured out solutions
for the problems that you are facing try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
to reach more of the right people zip
recruiter posts your job to 100 plus job
sites zip recruiters smart technology
finds great matches for your job and
then lets you invite the most qualified
people to apply for your job their
pricing is really straightforward and
you can stick to your budget with no
surprises team up with a hiring partner
such as
sip recruiter that understands what you
need four out of five employers you post
on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day go to this
exclusive web address for free
ziprecruiter.com Knowles that is
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire 2024.
new poll out from Kaplan this is the
national Republican primary survey so
again the primary is going to come down
to State polls but still the national
stuff tells you something Trump is at 48
so 37 points above his next
rival pretty good place for Trump to be
the next rival though is not Rhonda
Santos who had been the number two
candidate for the whole race
the next rival Vivek ramaswamy
who's at 11 so not exactly close to 48
but still that's a major major victory
for Rama Swami DeSantis one point below
at 10 percent
Pence at eight which is pretty
impressive actually given Pence's
current tensions within the GOP pretty
impressive that he's at eight Christy
down at four Haley at Forrest got it two
burgum got those bergamentum bergam
momentum at one ASA Hutchinson at zero
where he belongs we're still in in silly
season of course
the reasonable like this matters though
heading into the debate
which we're not very close to is because
it's going to show you who's got Mojo
it's going to affect the momentum going
into that debate
head DeSantis been the clear and Away
number two candidate going into the
debate then a lot of the focus would be
on him for better or worse people might
be attacking him but also he would
command a lot of the attention
now
even if DeSantis is still statistically
tied with Vivek the fact that this guy
who came out of nowhere has been able to
according to one poll actually unseat
him as number two and according to other
polls at least get you know somewhere up
in the same vicinity that doesn't look
as good for DeSantis and so people are
just going to be looking at other
candidates especially if you're a
republican who hates Donald Trump you're
you're now going to be more open-minded
to the other candidates whereas perhaps
previously you might have thought
DeSantis is the guy we've all got to
Rally around the momentum here really
really matters who has got the Mojo
another candidate is popping up this is
in New Hampshire Chris Christie is is
now number two in New Hampshire so he's
surpassed Governor DeSantis in New
Hampshire again it's statistically tied
Trump is Far and Away winning uh
Christie is at nine percent DeSantis is
at eight percent still this matters
because of the Mojo and because
Christie's going to be in this debate
so if if
and by the way who called it who
freaking called it I'm now back on the
chrysosons
I'm now back on the croissants my gut
instinct
I think may have been right or at least
plausible which is don't sleep on
Christy I don't think the guy's gonna be
president but he could have a moment
especially because he's a good debater
don't forget that moment when he took
out Rubio
he's really Adept on his feet and the
other candidates on that stage the vague
is is good I mean Vivek is pretty quick
quick-witted in that way and DeSantis is
good DeSantis gives great speeches I
heard DeSantis give a speech at the
Claremont Institute once I thought it
was an excellent excellent speech I'm
not saying the guy can't talk but he
compared to the other candidates on on
this stage he is not known for his quick
responses his fast little zingers that's
not he's good at beating up the media in
press conferences he's he's reasonably
good at giving speeches but that's not
where he's going to shine and so that's
why the momentum going into the debate
is going to be so important because
especially I'm just looking at the field
here those two guys Christy and Vivek
they're gonna they're gonna do pretty
well whether Trump is there or not
they're going to they're going to be
more impressive on the debate stage I
predict than probably anyone else man
what a great clip that was now
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show channel see you next time